what was that
i was just going to say why do i say
dumb [ __ ] all the time you just launched
into it
hey
check out my tech talks you want to
check out my big box you wanna check out
check them out my chick check out my
tick tock bro you flexing your tick
tocks at me yeah i'm flashing you check
this out yeah yeah yeah check this out
[Music]
i feel like this one gets better the
more i look at it i just this dude is
way beyond his years
everyone's living at the moment and he's
like what if they're all dead tomorrow
what if ryze step up the moment
[Laughter]
dude's thinking about his future and his
afterlife well at the same time
i love it his friend is like dude what
the [ __ ] are you looking at yeah he's
like what are you looking at it's the
sun
what is beautiful
honestly look at those guard rays
video game
[Music]
i respect it you know the older i get
the more i'm the guy in the right and
not the people on the left
that's how you know you're getting older
oh yeah moving on i think you'll like
this one
americans call a rock melon a cantaloupe
what i just found out that americans
caught a flicky flicky willy dogger of
[ __ ] light
[Laughter]
i like the
because it's like arugula and cilantro
or
it's a
rocket and arugula rock and it's like
yeah i get that one but
a rocket melon a rock melon a rocket no
it's a rock melon it's a cantaloupe even
though i know that
yeah
don't put your dick in there god
say that again
say what again say whatnot do you want
that what's your name come on this is a
rock got it all right cool oh look at it
oh ew ew jack eww
oh yeah
yeah before
you made the joke jack are you for it
because i'm epic
oh so you're epic so yeah so you're
african i'm childish got it
we're looking at tick tocks all right
let's just blend in with the environment
all right jack we both live in brighton
yeah this could be you and me yeah i
know where this is
i know this is
i love the old lady she's so good
[Music]
and then the pandemic happened and no
more fun bye bye honestly it wasn't this
guy but there was another guy who would
dress up in like a fairy outfit and he
had chalk and he would draw stuff in the
chalk all the time and play music and he
would just dance around at the churchill
shopping center oh really i've never
seen that yeah we're just not that far
from here so he's on his turf right here
he is yeah this is going to be drama
when didn't happen wait i'm going to
follow this account init brighton oh any
i wonder if there's anything else in
there it's brought in any how famous is
brighton have you ever wondered how
conspiracy
oh my god
yeah this is you this is literally me
what the [ __ ] march 28 2003 brighton's
west pier was mysteriously attacked by a
group of arsonists and by the time
firefighters arrived the fire had spread
too rapidly for them to safely fight the
fire so these are this is harry potter
music in the background bro just pour
water on it it's literally on water yeah
i just drive jet skis near it and spray
i love how the first time i came to
brighton you went like full rabbit hole
conspiracy on the pier for me you like
convinced me of the conspiracy i had no
idea why what are your mentors to
convince you it's one fact and one fact
only they burn it down on purpose man
comment how did it burn down it was on
fire
that's how it burns down okay cool
well this is just funny to me sorry this
is you and maya this is me and my uh
when your favorite human goes out and
you're stuck with the other one
shut the hell up [ __ ]
[Laughter]
why does she hate me so much why is it
so bad oh i'm so sorry you have to be
alone with me for like five minutes when
my set goes down
so sorry you're the screaming video game
man
she's [ __ ] death dude
[Laughter]
oh she might hear a thing and somehow
she still hears you we had such a monty
python moment do you remember with the
parrot the parrot just dead you know
when he yells at it oh yeah we had like
that with maya being beth i'm like i
might say she's you know she can't hear
us right she's like no she can hear her
very good maya
[Music]
she doesn't care oh this is a bb moment
what the [ __ ]
i was waiting for the first cat to do
something and then spider legs came out
oh my god it's happening
it's it's attachable legs right
no it isn't where are the real legs what
sarah's real legs what no he's just he's
just a little different
no
all right i respect it uh have you seen
the movie sharknado i haven't actually
okay there's an easter egg in it that's
great we're watching sharknado 2 the
second one because we hate ourselves
the flight attendant wants to see was
that kelly osprey yeah that was kelly
oxford oh tara reid what a weird
crossover yeah
wants her to sign her book that she
wrote
about surviving the sharknado
the butt
i can't even get it out the buttons
listen to tables 3-1 are pretty common
available
most of the time you use the galaxy tab
beyond those buttons are other buttons
and symbols used in the tabs i love her
signature also
for the record
she signs her name the way she wrote her
name at the complete cycle like a second
grader you can clearly see these this is
the instruction manual to a galaxy tab
please hit play please hit place
[Laughter]
okay oh my god that's detail that that's
how you know they put extra effort yeah
you might as well just put in that latin
thing where it's just like laura
or the fitnessgram pacer test oh man
yeah that's just lazy and i love it
well done kelly osbourne good job what a
credit to have to your name absolutely
you will know that the living god
is
there's so much happening in this clip i
don't know where to start
and among his commented said bro what
hell yeah
it's such a weird meme preachers like
that are basically just like the cringy
teachers in school who are just like
right kids i know about it among us
yeah but raise your hand if you're sauce
huh
i don't think i ever had a t-shirt like
that yeah i didn't either they just
exist on tick-tock apparently apparently
it feels like an american thing
yeah i'm cool right like me please you
know what i don't know if it's better or
worse to have a teacher like that at
least they're trying my teachers are
just like a [ __ ] book just just learn
i think we had a lunch lady that was
kind of like that we ever we made her
cry one time because she we didn't like
her chicken
it was good
felix yeah read the read the top comment
on that video
show the people
oh lord
do you think that's what they said at
the last supper judas was like yo
jesus the imposter vote him out
i think he's sauce bro
he says like one of you is going to
betray me
and judas were like i don't know can't
be me
they were literally playing among us
back in the day it all makes sense
it's not me
playing mafia
wherever is the werewolf put your hand
up
i've never found a use for a bent
screwdriver
i don't remember why i saved this this
is for
let me show you
this is called a trim screwdriver and
they really only have one used
they turn these screws electricians like
them because i guess you can spin it
faster
it's faster
yeah
that's pretty cool sorry sometimes i
just save stuff because i won't let me
show you what it looks like
you got the phone set up why for
electrical switches and not just
everything
um because
it's just those are kind of fiddly i
think
maybe sideways you see
oh my god i hope you're better at using
the screwdriver than your camera
maybe this is why you saved it
what is happening
it's so funny it's making me so angry is
he happy to be doing this yeah
yesterday yesterday i hope so i don't
know either way i'm pissed off
[Laughter]
i legitimately forgot about it and then
i saw it again i'm like oh that's right
i wanted to see him screwdriver you have
to follow for part two oh i see that's
fair at least now you can change time in
tech talks it used to not be able to and
it was the worst i know it's so annoying
you're living an ordinary life but
you're jeremy
oh my god
isn't that spot on oh my god oh my god
if she wanted to see
you seeking
[Music]
oh my god oh
see it's fun in the beginning because
it's like oh charismatic like energetic
happy people and then 100 videos in
you're like um
they're always like oh wow
humans aren't meant to exist like
there's no other
new ones your personality oh wow that's
so cool
wow everything you've told me is just a
lie
i'm sure he's like that all the time
outside his videos absolutely from my
experience meeting youtubers and
influencers they're always the exact
same
outside of their videos but sometimes
they are dead that's true
[Music]
it's going to be us jack
clean
clean did you see that that was clean i
wasn't doing anything i was fixing his
porridge
it was dirty
yo shakespeare
i saw one yesterday of a dude tried to
steal something and they had a pickup
truck with a sprinkler in it
and when they try and steal a package
they just spray them with the sprinkler
ah
how is package theft this big a deal
have you ever had a package stolen no
i don't think i've ever stolen no
british people in it they don't do it
yeah i feel like it just doesn't happen
here it's an american sort of trend i
think stop stealing each other's [ __ ]
jeff bezos needs that money actually it
did happen once and it wasn't american i
think about it
really yeah
what happened like it just someone stole
it [ __ ] it said delivered lost yo if
you're watching this yeah and you stole
pewdiepie's package they don't it's fine
don't i'm over it i'm over it bro i'm
over it's all right all right i'm not
gonna make a video about it you should
have you seen this one jay no i look
forward to watching it with you
okay the gist of this game is to not
laugh basically i'm i'm familiar with
the concept you are i figured you would
be so why don't we
why don't we play along jack okay all
right i like the second and you at home
as well oh man
oh
[Music]
oh my god i can't
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] you can do it man come on
[Music]
[Laughter]
ghosts
you got it you got it you got it man
come on come
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh that poor guy
oh
god
oh that was way funnier than i thought
it was going to be yeah
it's so good that was great
here's what i need to teach edgar this
is the goal all right
you want a milk bone you built like a
milk bone
let me get a woo
come on give me a word
a longer one come on
i know you got it
there you go yeah
[Applause]
sign
shut him up get him going get him play
fortnite with ninja let's get it [ __ ]
yeah
the game that makes careers
oh oh uh yeah i mean you're a martha's
fan i've literally been watching all of
them like back to back again
so good it's a very reward rewatchable
show is this the diabetes one
you clearly don't care so why don't you
just leave i would like to stay this
pertains to me i would like you to leave
why don't you go outside and take a shot
of insulin and have a nap okay why do
you always assume i have diabetes you
have a glass of apple juice and tell me
that you don't have diabetes okay
all right see just the noise you made
when you stood up i could
[Music]
that's a [ __ ] quick one yeah he's so
good oh jesus the office is the best
show i love how they're all just dying
oh man this poor puppy oh no i was
attacked by a snake
it was attack
i love that twilight theme
ah just copyrighted we'll have to change
it
[Laughter]
he's fine he's fine for the record the
dog is fine looked it up but it's just
so funny
he looks like it looks like there's a
filter on it yeah
all right watch this a classic
oh
what
i don't understand how this works
[Music]
this launches a rocket so if you steal
you're gonna go to jail for killing
somebody with that yeah it's like have
you ever seen those videos where it's
like why didn't we make these inventions
stick and it's like the car that has a
wheel on the back that like pivots it in
360 degrees
okay because that [ __ ] breaks super
easily and people do trouble right yeah
yeah for for dead will be injured yeah
what if he runs off with that in the
middle of a crowded area ah okay okay
wait so he this is his bag and he's
supposed to steal it and then it detects
it and it just like
locks him in
how does it detect it i mean how does
that lock him in
i'm sorry that's true just tilt it
sideways and run yeah bro just run
oh so much effort just
have this belongings be stolen most of
the case has been taken up by the
mechanism
i don't
what are you storing in there sandwich
they didn't really have practical ideas
back in the day did they i mean you
stored in your briefcase is that
expensive
[Applause]
what
it's modern art
hey it could be honestly making it soup
what are you doing making soup
cheer making soup
how did this come to
come to be why did someone make this i
don't know why do humans do anything why
did i save this why am i watching it
why am i here helping yeah
okay okay okay okay you will laugh jack
have you seen this no guaranteed laugh
i'm giving this one my guaranteed slap
laugh jacksepticeye okay yeah a classic
throw my head back
[Laughter]
and the dog at the end
no don't do it bro
[Laughter]
so yeah
damn
he said no with an aussie accent
no
wait what's the dog at the end doing
just comes out of frame it's so [ __ ]
funny
got these 20 foot high reinforced stone
i wonder if it's the same in ireland but
yeah this one hit me hearing balls to
repel invaders and four exits across the
camp if you're in need of a quick escape
and as you can see it's very much intact
[Laughter]
you've
this happens way too often dude i'm like
why why why why even have the why
exactly wait they took down something
like that i don't know are we all about
like preserving here we can't even they
won't even destroy the red phone boxes
in brighton because they're like a part
of a natural history thing yeah you can
like buy the phone box because you're
not allowed to destroy them cool good
but this
yeah it's a sheep
scared grass now english history is
basically trust me mate
this is what we mean
i think marx just sent me this
oh are they going to kiss
see it's not funny because you know
they're going to do it right
but it's kind of cute
he's kind of cute man here it comes
it's kind of sweet man
oh they lost
no love always finds a way
they're kissing
[Music]
is this love
this could be you and me jack
[Music]
[Laughter]
say why don't we have such lame pets
jack huh i know yeah we were watching
videos last night and there's like cats
falling asleep in weird positions i'm
like
why don't you do that you never do that
all you do is yell at me and yeah
i kind of i love bb though super chill
cat yeah he's cool but still i want to
put some glasses in the watch on him and
have him high five people yeah right
they didn't think it's not a dog that's
a doubt
oh
hell yeah
oh this could be uh
this is why this is why we never get the
good stuff
the good memes
no i hate you
i love this sound
cats are such [ __ ]
i love you i love you leave me the [ __ ]
alone for at least a year
i just love the sound
a hunter
oh yeah he is he killed a spider the
other day oh my god
together but not like this he's not like
a heat-seeking missile
yeah wow
protein dude you gotta protein
you gotta try it i
should i was say we had like a big-ass
spider in our kitchen the other day we
sick bb on him and he like beat him into
submission hell yeah [ __ ] him up he
didn't eat him though he missed out on
some good protein oh bb well that's kind
of gross like don't eat the spider no no
a certain dominance nah that's gross
nasty disgusting here comes the boy
yeah we should get top hats we should
headlights honestly
yeah and owls okay yeah like i'm on our
shoulder like harry potter is cool right
i think so owls are real that's true
they can be trained we're halfway there
let's go let's get it we just lack
motivation that's all that's true too
lazy stanford gloucestershire where
sorry in sanford gloucestershire yeah
it's actually a city in somerset called
wells but the main high street is
exactly what it was like in hot fuzz
complete with the famous crown pub and
right next to that oh my god you can go
there you can go there
and just outside the high street we
tried to catch a swan in the park
still dorky
where they actually have a wanted poster
for the swan in the window we enjoyed
our cornettos by the fountain and popped
into the crowd to see their signed
police jacket and enjoy a pint of lager
and cranberry juice before heading back
to our tent to watch the movie
hell yeah that's a good thing that is so
fun i i have to go there
i have to for the greater good for those
of you it's from the movie hot fuzz who
don't know the best movie ever made uh
yeah it's great film stanford was a
made-up place in police entrance exam
for years before the film really i don't
know i kind of want to google it now i
don't know i guess we'll never know
check this out stanford whoa
hell yeah
there are pets
and he got trees yeah dude
sees a puddle and he's like
he sees a puddle on tv yeah and he gets
scared
this is motherflopper okay okay yeah
have you seen these no but i'm excited
about your time i might slap a jack
laugh i might slide
[Music]
[Laughter]
more jiu-jitsu kaizen in my life hell
yeah have you seen this no okay
one punch man right here baby
it's even ready
yeah that's pure raw
[Laughter]
power this is like the nightmare you
have right when you're trying to punch
someone in a dream and you can't hit
them
have you ever had that dream
sometimes yeah yeah
this is that happening in real life
let's go let's go
let me try it now
respectable yeah yeah yeah
[Laughter]
oh my god how are you allowed to get up
and put your trousers on in the morning
how do you not just fall over dude hey
hey come on
come on
come on although i do have a story about
me trying one of these out on a holiday
when i was like
i went 12.
punch it and i was in sandals
because we're in lanzarote you know it's
a hot place it's down by the coast of
africa absolutely
yes i had sandals on i went to punch it
and my sandals slipped under the machine
and it ripped all the skin on the top of
my foot back and i ended up with this
like
like a whole bunch of layers of skin on
the top of my [ __ ] pull back
it was so gross bro
and i missed the thing so
i'm that guy i kind of want to see that
tick tock now can you do you have that
i wish
so you you have empathy for this man i
understand
that's a bro trust me oh yeah wow jack
thank you for letting me show you some
fresh tick-tocks
no problem it's always a good day yeah
that's really fun
down i don't upload anymore there's no
point
okay well can you tell them to check out
me then check out
i upload way too much for my own sake
please guys
do you guys love reddit so this video
nice shout out shout out to you you
might even see every now and then
all right bye
bye you thought it was gay
but true relevance never really died
welcome to the first undead game use any
item in your inventory and make memes
inside tuber simulator add some of our
patented stickers in there stickers our
emotions means our emotions express your
emotions with me
share them for likes share them for love
get up for free
and who knows
maybe i'll review your memes the
greatest honor of all time full circle
baby download it make a meme
[Music]
we need subtitles on this